[Music]  she started it and it's time for her to  finish it  Katy Perry addresses her infamous Taylor  Swift view during Monday night's carpool  karaoke with James Corden I tried to  talk to her about it and she she  wouldn't speak are you trying to talk to  her about you did the phone call I do  the right thing any phone call fumble it  was a full shutdown and then she writes  the song about me and I'm like okay cool  cool cool that's how you want to deal  with it  karma but I bye but go on  what I want to say is that like I'm  ready for that PS to be done now  ye there is the law of cause and effect  you do something and there's gonna be a  reaction and trust me daddy there's  gonna be a reaction it doesn't take much  digging to speculate that Katy's new  single swish-swish is the Karma she's  talking about and she keeps fresh